on n'appelle pas soir du premier ordre
les passoires qui ne laisse passer ni
les nouilles nil où on n'appelle pas
soir du second tour
les passoires qui laisse passer et les
nouilles et l'eau on n'appelle pas soir
du troisième ordre ou passoire complexe
les passoires qui laisse passer quelques
fois le nul on est quelques fois pas
pour qu'une passoire complexe laisse
passer l'eau et pas les nouilles
il faut et il suffit que le diamètre des
trous soit notablement inférieur au
diamètre des nouilles pour qu'une
passoire complexe laisse passer les
nouilles et palau il faut et il suffit
que le diamètre des trous soit
notablement inférieur au diamètre de
l'eau
quant aux bars soir du premier rang qui
nous laisse passer ni les nouilles ni
l'eau il y en a 2 200 les passoires qui
ne laisse passer ni les nouilles ni
l'eau ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre et
celle qui ne laisse passer ni les
nouilles ni l'eau que dans un sens
seulement c'est pas soir là on les
appelle des casseroles il y a trois
sortes de casseroles les casseroles avec
la queue à droite les casseroles avec la
queue à gauche et les casseroles avec
pas de queue du tout mais celle là on
les appelle des autobus
il est à trois sortes de thau bus les
autobus qui marchent à droite les
autobus qui marchent à gauche et les
autobus qui ne marche ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre
mais ceux là on les appelle des
casseroles il y a trois sortes de
casseroles les casseroles avec la cure à
droite
des casseroles
non